we're constantly bombarded with trailers
posters and concept art for franchise
films
but on the flip side there are quite a
few that have successfully stayed under
the radar
from indie comedies to biblical epics
let's take a look at some of the sequels
you didn't know were being made we
thought this day would never come
but it looks like ridley scott is
heading back to ancient rome
nearly 20 years after the original
gladiator hit theaters scott
is finally making a sequel to the story
of maximus decimus meridius
of course old maximus is busy walking
through wheat fields and heavens so
what's the sequel going to be about
are you not entertained are you not
entertained
well according to producer walter f
parks the film is going to start about
25 to 30 years after the original ended
part 2 will focus on lucius the son of
maximus's old flame lucila
while spencer treat clark played lucius
in the first film we don't know if he's
going to reprise his role for gladiator
2.
however we do know that peter craig will
be working on the screenplay and he's a
guy with some impressive credits to his
name
including the town both mockingjay
movies and the upcoming top gun sequel
and with scott at the helm we're pretty
sure we'll be entertained
as the crew of the nostromo learned the
hard way all the way back in 1979
it's hard to kill an alien in reflecting
on his landmark sci-fi horror film on
its 40th anniversary director ridley
scott told variety that a third prequel
the follow-up to 2012's prometheus and
2017's alien covenant
is indeed on the way despite generally
positive critical reviews
covenant underperformed at the box
office throwing the future of the
franchise into uncertainty
but following disney's acquisition of
fox both scott and
alien's new studio home seem eager to
return to the sinister stars yet again
as for what this third prequel might be
about one thing is for sure
it won't follow the format of the
original alien speaking to the hollywood
reporter scott talked about the need for
the franchise to continue to evolve in
order to succeed
this next alien film tentatively titled
alien awakening is still
in the very early stages and none of the
cast of covenant has yet been asked to
return
still scott maintains that it's
happening he'll be directing and
that the film is currently in the script
phase
it's been almost 20 years since
audiences followed effervescent sorority
girl l
woods to harvard law school in legally
blonde you
got into harvard law what like it's hard
she continued to ascend the professional
ladder in 2003's legally blonde 2
red white and blonde which saw l head to
washington dc
now l is back for a third adventure in
addition to starring as
l reese witherspoon will also act as a
producer this time through her hello
sunshine banner
originally legally blonde scribes
kirsten kiwi smith and karen mccullough
were attached to pen the script
but since then the office alum mindy
kaling and brooklyn 99 director dan gore
have stepped in to completely rewrite
the screenplay
no director has yet been announced for
the film nor have any plot details been
revealed
sources originally told deadline that
the threquel will be much in the spirit
of the first film
which saw elle draw on her fashion sense
optimism and strong sense of sisterhood
to defy the patriarchy
lift up the women around her and look
great doing it while that quote referred
to the first script by smith and
mccullough
we imagine that kaling and gore's
screenplay for legally blonde 3 will
also embrace the original film's themes
of female empowerment
taking l on a new legal adventure that
hopes to appeal to longtime
fans and newcomers alike jim henson's
cult classic fantasy labyrinth has a
die-hard following thanks to its
fantastical and creepy storytelling
henson's imaginative creature creations
and of course
an iconic performance from david bowie
as jareth the goblin king
making a sequel to henson's final
feature film seems like a pretty
intimidating task
but the jim henson company feels up to
it news of the labyrinth sequel first
broke in 2017 with
don't breathe filmmaker feta alvarez
attached to direct
however alvarez announced in april of
2020 that he decided to step away from
the film
the project didn't stay rudderless for
long though in may of 2020 deadline
reported that doctor strange director
scott derrickson has stepped in to helm
the highly anticipated sequel
while we don't yet have any details on
the story that will bring us back into
the world of labyrinth
insiders have said the sequel would
indeed be a continuation of the story
that began
in the original film but that the
character of the goblin king would not
be making an appearance
although rumor has it that a third
sherlock holmes film starring robert
downey jr has always been a part of the
warner brothers plan the actor has spent
the past decade anchoring the marvel
cinematic universe as the
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist tony stark
saving the world every couple of years
is a draining gig and downey's superhero
commitments kept him from being able to
take up the detective's trademark pipe
for a third time
however now that downey has finally
exited the mcu for good he finally has
time to team up with jude laws watson
for one more case
the third sherlock holmes film will be
helmed by rocketman director dexter
fletcher a departure from the first two
films which were both directed by guy
richie
while sherlock holmes 3 was originally
scheduled to release on christmas day
2020
it has since been pushed back a year and
will supposedly now be striding
confidently into theaters december 21st
2021
the hitman's bodyguard wasn't exactly a
critical success
earning a pretty lousy 39 approval
rating over on rotten tomatoes
but the movie did pretty well at the box
office pulling in 177 million dollars
worldwide
after all how can an audience say no to
the combined charisma of ryan reynolds
and samuel l jackson
these two dudes are as charming as it
gets so fans of the first film will be
happy to know that the hitman's
bodyguard is getting a sequel
confusingly titled the hitman's wife's
bodyguard
reynolds and jackson are both returning
and soma hayak is coming back as the
titular wife
according to the hollywood reporter the
plot will find reynolds bodyguard trying
to live a peaceful life when he gets
mixed up again with jackson's hitman
the movie will also star familiar names
like morgan freeman
antonio banderas and richard e grant and
promises plenty more wild action
your move creeps robocop is back
according to deadline the cyborg star is
returning to the big screen
although it seems this new film is going
to mess around with the continuity
the original robocop was directed by
paul verhoeven and it made quite a
killing when it was released in 1987.
after two sequels starring original
actor peter weller the franchise was
rebooted in 2014 with actor joel
kinnaman in the title role
the remake wasn't nearly as popular as
the first film and sadly for mr kinnaman
it looks like the new film is going to
ignore the recent remake
the latest entry in the franchise will
be called robocop returns
and it began life as a script written
right after the original was a hit
sadly the script never got made but now
mgm is giving it another go
sadly peter weller won't be returning to
reprise his role which leaves the door
open for yet another actor to go
cybernetic though neil blomkamp was
initially attached to direct he
announced in august 2019 that scheduling
conflicts had forced him to depart the
project tweeting that he was quote
excited to watch it in theaters with
other fans in november
of 2019 orion pitchers announced that
little monster's director abe forsythe
had taken up the helm of robocop returns
and will be giving the screenplay
a fresh rewrite when the megs swam into
the public consciousness
some might have scoffed at this
ridiculous sounding jaws rip-off
but the megalodon movie earned some
serious coin at the box office pulling
in more than half a billion dollars
worldwide
after all this is a movie where jason
statham goes to war with a gigantic
shark who doesn't want to see that after
audiences went into a feeding frenzy for
the film plans were almost immediately
set in motion for a sequel
we don't really know what the plot will
be but since the meg is actually based
on a series of books by steve
alton the sequel might draw on the next
novel which features an even bigger
shark
and the giant crocodile-like kronosaurus
in other words the meg-2 might feature
statham fighting a monstrous shark
and a dinosaur fish which is a major win
for moviegoers everywhere
megalodon coming off of the runaway
success of 2018's crazy rich asians
it would be surprising if the opulent
film didn't earn a sequel
and in fact it's getting too based on
kevin kwan's books of the same names
china rich girlfriend and rich people
problems are both
moving ahead at warner brothers although
it may be a while before we get to see
them
due to the busy schedules of the
franchise's a-list cast and director
john m
chu it may be a while before everyone
can get together again for the next two
installments in the crazy rich asian
saga
however producer nina jacobson says that
the plan is to shoot both sequels back
to back so that fans aren't waiting
years between the second and third films
as for when this back to back shooting
might happen
it could still be a ways off according
to actress gemma chan
filming on china rich girlfriend and
rich people problems will begin sometime
in 2020 at the earliest we appear to be
in the midst of an eddie murphy
renaissance
after gradually fading from the
spotlight since his heyday in the 80s
and 90s
murphy is suddenly back in a big way the
comedy legend gave
a critically acclaimed performance in
2019's dolomite is my name
made a triumphant return to saturday
night live as host
lined up new stand-up comedy specials
for netflix
and announced sequels to two of his
biggest movies from the 80s
while the coming to america sequel is
the one getting the most attention
murphy's also planning to return to
beverly hills cop
marking the fourth installment in the
beverly hills cop franchise this newest
sequel will also be a collaboration
between murphy and netflix after
paramount previously pulled the plug on
a planned beverly hills cop 4 back in
2016.
murphy will be reprising his role as
axel foley the detroit cop who
repeatedly finds himself traveling to
beverly hills to investigate various
crimes
the first beverly hills cop was a smash
success at the box office in 1984
rising to become one of the highest
grossing comedies of all time
although the sequels in 1987 and 1994
brought in diminishing returns
there's no word yet on when beverly
hills cop 4 will move into production at
netflix but considering how fast
murphy's star is rising once again
we wouldn't be surprised if the
streaming giant decides to strike while
the iron is hot
after two tomb raider films starring
angelina jolie in 2001
and 2003 the franchise was rebooted in
2018 with alicia vikander in the lead
role
now that new franchise is also getting a
sequel currently set for release march
19
2021. the candor is set to reprise her
role as lara croft and ben wheatley will
direct a script
penned by his wife and frequent
collaborator amy jump
adapted from the popular tomb raider
video game series the first film follows
adventurous
archaeologist lara croft as she journeys
into perilous locations in search of her
missing father
although little is known about the plot
of the sequel the first film set up
one possible storyline with its reveal
that her father's former business
partner anna miller
heads up the very company that was set
to release the world-ending virus that
croft prevented
the door is wide open for kristin scott
thomas to return for the sequel stepping
more fully into the role of villain than
she did in the first film
while writer and director kevin smith
was in quarantine in 2020 he did some
polishing work on a few old script ideas
one of those is the sequel to 1995's
mall rats which he penned under the
working title twilight of the maulrats
the plot of the original film pivots
around a dating game show being filmed
at a shopping mall
and stars jeremy london jason lee claire
forlani
shannon doherty ben affleck and michael
rooker
this time instead of a game show the
plot will focus on some sort of
convention taking place
at the mall of the original cast smith
confirmed that shannon darity will be
returning for the sequel
and that she's already read the script
and loved it he also tweeted in may of
2020 that jason lee was in the process
of reading the script although lee
hasn't officially signed on yet
joining doherty for twilight of the maul
rats will be jay and silent bob reboot
co-star aparna brielle
who smith says will be at the center of
the sequel as the daughter of lee's
character
brody bruce twilight of the mall rats
doesn't have a clear release date yet
but smith hopes to start shooting soon
after the runaway success of the hunger
games series which dominated the box
office from 2012 to 2015
and moved more than 65 million books in
the u.s
it seemed likely that audiences would
one day get the opportunity to return to
the dystopian world of pan
am one way or another sure enough in
june of 2019 publisher scholastic
announced that it would be releasing
another novel by suzanne collins set in
the hunger games world
and the ballad of songbirds and snakes
hit shelves on may 19
2020 set 64 years before the events of
the hunger games the ballot of songbirds
and snakes follows an 18 year old corey
elena snow
who would eventually grow up to become
the ruthless ruler of pan am and colin's
original novels
a film version of the ballad of
songbirds and snakes was confirmed by
lionsgate prior to the book's release to
be directed by hunger games veteran
francis lawrence
fans of charlize theron in action rules
are in for a treat
the mad max fury road and the old guard
star will soon be slipping back into the
platinum wigs of lorraine broughton her
enigmatic character from atomic blonde
theron told the hollywood reporter in an
interview in july of 2020
that an atomic blonde sequel was in
active development and that the lockdown
due to the coronavirus pandemic was
actually helping move the process along
giving theron and the writers more time
to work on the script over zoom
also starring john goodman james mcavoy
and sophia boutella
the first film found theron's ruthless
mi6 agent investigating a murder
and dodging double crosses coming from
every angle in cold war era berlin
no details have yet been revealed about
the plot of atomic blonde 2 but if the
first film is any indication we expect
another twisting spy
caper with plenty of hard-hitting action
some films get theatrical or streaming
sequels while others get turned into tv
series
but if you're the nicolas cage starring
treasure hunting film national treasure
you get both
the long-awaited threquel to 2004's
national treasure and 2007's national
treasure book of secrets seems to
finally be moving forward at disney and
they've tapped bad boys for
scribe chris renmer to write the script
but that's not all
national treasure will also find new
life as a disney plus tv series which
producer jerry bruckheimer says is
currently in the development process
while the tv series will feature the
same concept but a young cast
national treasure 3 is expected to
reunite the cast from the first two
films
presumably including diane kruger justin
bartha and of course
cage as protagonist benjamin franklin
gates
also expected to return as director john
turtletop who helmed both of the first
two films
although bruckheimer says the disney
plus series is currently further along
in the development pipeline he's hopeful
that both projects will ultimately come
to fruition
delivering a veritable treasure trove of
new national treasure adventures
for anyone who spent their childhood
staying up late at night reading the
spine tingling scary stories to tell in
the dark short story collections by
alvin schwartz and illustrator stephen
gamel
the news that master horror filmmaker
guillermo del toro was adapting some of
those stories into a feature film was
likely creepy music to their ears
the scary stories to tell in the dark
film directed by andre overdoll arrived
in 2019
weaving a number of the chilling short
stories from the books into a single
narrative
the film was a success receiving mostly
positive reviews and performing
respectably at the box office
in april 2020 a sequel was officially
announced which would reunite overdoll
and del toro for another round of spooky
tales
set in 1968 scary stories to tell in the
dark followed a group of teens who are
horrified to realize that the terrifying
stories written in a book they found are
becoming a reality
once again del toro will be crafting the
story for the second film
although he hasn't revealed yet whether
scary stories to tell in the dark too
will continue the story that began in
the first film which left the door wide
open for a sequel
or if it will follow brand new
characters and events unrelated to the
first film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one